you're heading out on tour after this
with the weekend so that'll be great
you will be going out on tour correct
yes i will yes what he's trying to say
is tell everybody here it's gonna happen
yes north america i'm coming you heard
doja telling e.t at the grammys last
month that she will be heading out on
tour with the weekend oh my god
i'm very excited i'm very very excited
but now she may need to change those
plans after suffering a health scare the
26 year old musician shared on twitter
thursday that she had surgery on her
left tonsil which had an abscess in it
quote my whole throat is
so i might have some bad news for y'all
coming soon
some fans speculate that doge's drinking
and vaping at the billboard music awards
over the weekend is to blame the moment
your name was called you grabbed your
drink you chugged it headed to the stage
what was going through your mind i was
shocked and i and i i ran up i was like
i need something because i feel like my
first speech was flat a little bit so
i don't know um
yeah it was great it was amazing but she
shut down that theory tweeting that her
tonsils got infected before the award
show dosia says she was taking
antibiotics but forgot about them and
after a long day of drinking wine and
vaping she got a nasty ass growth on her
tonsil and had to get surgery the rapper
describes the procedure in detail she
says the painful process made her cry
for hours but i'm okay yeah pray to god
dogis fans flooded her with tweets
encouraging her to get rid of her vape
pen but she says it's simply not that
easy quote throwing them away just
instills panic i'm addicted but i'm not
weak i'ma go cold turkey for now but
hopefully my brain doesn't need it at
all by then
so get out of here with that throw it
away then queen
that doesn't help anybody and it just
sounds condescending to anybody who's
actually struggling with nicotine
addiction i've tried all that throw it
away before doesn't work looks like fans
changed their tune because just minutes
later the singer tweeted that she was
near tears after reading so many
supportive and reassuring messages
thank you so much while we continue to
send good healing energy dosia's way she
certainly has a lot of impressive
accomplishments to celebrate not only
did she win her first grammy this year
and score big at the billboard music
awards how'd it feel you uh had quite a
few trophies to hold in your hand over
there yeah yes a lot yeah i've never
done that i don't know how people do
that and it looks comfortable but i
managed some somehow but she also
crushed her set at coachella
[Music]
[Music]
and with nearly 25 million followers
dozier continues to be one of the
reigning queens of tick tock
this is fine right like this is cute
but right here ready
this is cute too
there's nothing wrong with this
however
[Music]